okay and welcome to this video playing
FM called start yeah I think he has no
name in there so doesn't really help to
have to check i recently played him i
think in one of the live broadcast in
precisely the same variation okay that
we had I think he'll precisely the same
the same position I know as I am yeah
that was the first game of the recent
broadcast and has never made it on video
because we had this broadcasting issue
so this was a game that i won but yeah
it's one of those that never really got
on the channel mmm roped it to maybe
yeah just double them okay okay so go
into 88 this is a common idea but I
don't know here if this is helping I
mean II five hangs and what is he doing
now going back maybe
hmm it just goes back there is night
efore in the in the position so I cannot
go nite a for let's say or at least it
looks looks dubious so maybe go out of
out of the sea file just a little
improving move
native force and annoying going for them
maybe I can sue prepare night a for the
rook t3 and then that move or something
silly as mighty for the the long-term
issue for black is that somehow it's
like white has an extra partner the
three against two here is a constant
constant issue hmm wow wow what's the
idea there night h5 don't know I really
don't know have many i have many
interesting ideas even look d7 is
interesting but maybe let's just play a
prophylactic rules yeah get out of get
out of this and now night night here
becomes more interesting yeah here have
beehive a thought but ok it's not that's
not a huge issue as seem ok maybe up for
93 m
yeah I probably has gained from all the
same activating his night down hmm ok I
didn't play that too well
that's probably a very weird idea
whatever I have what I hate did yet
getting the night to d3 you can even
play f6 it's a bit over no ff3 now right
and then c5 Bishop Bishop g5 as possible
but be fine I can go here actually be
five and then c5
maybe just this I know I yes night be 70
that looks very very weird he's 66 s
attacked so I know he kept us that with
the rook I know how stupid it was a bad
idea I just I just overlooked at the
rook is covering the whole thing okay oh
yeah I'm stupid it was bad okay I can
take it yeah now here for up to seven
yeah I'm you can just go rook da de it's
not quite clear what my movies this is
bishop hitting III is very annoying
very annoying
maybe this one is very shaky shaky
position my bishop has to be improved if
I can improve my bishop I'm okay so he
keeps it simple I wonder ever I'm
slightly better in this position
probably not no I'm not I'm not better
in any way no stupid idea actually hey
he can he can untangle easily him go
here
spish upon b7 is tricky own his TD sled
time warning trying to go F form getting
at his age for pawn
wow that's tough to evaluate take or not
okay shaking it should be six
wow I'm were see I cannot believe this
nonsense from this great position yeah
yeah I'm much worse i totally spoiled
that King geforce just winning here for
e3 Wow yes all the trade was bad it was
bad I can resign him wow that was
terrible white resides yeah in this end
game I mean I should never lose of
course I can go if for myself which I
wanted to do just the next move actually
I was just thinking that wow I can't go
bishops III first and so on but this is
this is really a check yeah this is
losing it just loses but Jim bad but
very bad and gameplay I should go Bishop
f2 or something ah that's a wrong what
am i some times afterwards yeah if you
have if you are like level-headed after
the game we already asked yourself how
stupid can you be how can I take on
before and then play air form I mean
okay it's probably not not important if
I go F or not but it's just so obvious
how bad this is you can go all the way
up play Bishop g5 and wind it's so easy
it's so easy yeah that's maybe probably
a sign of bad bad shape somehow I am
that you that you don't don't see the
simple things this is I saw before I
just wanted to play it the next move I
was in the okay it doesn't matter what
kind of move audit and this is just a
total draw I am I have all pawns on
light squares and the bishop here i can
adjust i can chip shuffle forever and
can never never lose so we add and
chair yet i probably made some weird
decisions here with them with the night
queen bee to is winning for wine
according to the engine that's at strong
95 for bishopric see five that's a very
strong move I mean that this is no
goodness is quite easy to believe I
didn't really understand the idea at all
but I didn't make this is very strong
queen bee 295 is a huge threat yeah like
something like this just put it here
yeah this gets the whole thing back with
with interest Jim here this is nothing
okay wyd winsome comsys how with this
I'm just playing like it like it like a
[ __ ] at the moment here it's not so
difficult really I mean look at this
yeah the bishop is unleashed their own
age too and he's sitting in an awkward
pin for luke t 2 45 and his king is wide
open yeah why just flat-out winds he has
no movievanja he's in this in this
awkward pin and can just resign never
them I don't I don't play I don't play
well them okay thanks for watching guys